thank you thank you New Hampshire
because of a huge voter turnout and I
say you
we won and this is a message not just to
our opponents but to those who support
me as well that we will need to come
together in a few months and unite this
party and this nation because the
right-wing Republicans we oppose must
not be allowed to gain the presidency
and let us never forget Democrats and
progressives win when voter turnout is
high Republicans win when people are
demoralized and voter turnout is low the
people of the Hampshire have sent a
profound message to the political
establishment to the economic
establishment and by the way to the
media establishment
it is just too late for the same old
same old establishment politics and
establishment economics the people what
real change I hear this not just from
progressives but from conservatives and
for moderates is that we can no longer
continue to have a campaign finance
system in which wall street and the
billionaire class are able to buy
elections now I have been criticized
during this campaign for many many
things every single day that's okay
that's all right they're throwing
everything at me except the kitchen sink
and I have the feeling that kitchen sink
is coming pretty soon as well but what
our campaign is about is thinking big
not small it's about having the courage
to reject the status quo
this is the promise of America and this
is the promise we must keep alive for
future generations what began last week
in Iowa what vote is here in New
Hampshire confirmed tonight is nothing
short of the beginning of a political
revolution